[Musique]
cette année dans de nombreux pays des
citoyens en colère ont déferlé
massivement dans les rues pour
s'indigner contre système politique les
inégalités ou encore les violations des
droits humains je retrouve à paris
yasmine laver qui responsable de la
région maghreb et moyen-orient pour la
fédération internationale pour les
droits humains
merci beaucoup madame la veille dette
avec nous bonjour bonjour ça lui fait
plaisir surtout pour comprendre parce
qu'on a vu beaucoup de ce type de
contestation il n'y a pas de trêve à
noël la contestation populaire est
toujours un couple en val d'hérens
algérie en irak au liban et en a même
qui parle vous savez d'un deuxième
printemps arabes on conteste quoi dans
ces pays alors les revendications sont
effectivement assez similaire danser
dans ces trois pays
évidemment vous avez des des causes très
différente dans chaque pays
mais on a vraiment d une même demande de
droit de liberté de dignité et un désir
de changement radical de système et une
demandes de réformes profondes exprimés
soit à travers le rejet d'élite et de
classes dirigeantes que l'on juge
incompétent et corrompu ou à travers la
con la contestation d'inégalités
économie et social dans des pays qui
sont vous le savez profondément
inégalitaire par exemple au liban on
sait que environ 1% de la population la
plus aisée père soit 40% des revenus du
pays à l'échelle dans l'iowa
effectivement il ya des inégalités
sociales sont importantes et également
aux 150 et station ça se traduit puis on
l'a vu plusieurs fois par des violations
des droits humains de la part des forces
de l'ordre oui tout à fait donc vous
avez des violations des droits humains
qui sont à l'origine de ces mouvements
là principalement des droits économiques
et sociaux mais aussi des libertés qui
sont bafoués mais malheureusement
les réponses des autorités dans les
différents pays que ce soit en irak au
liban ou en algérie a été
essentiellement une répression
grandissante qui donne lieu en effet à
de graves violations des droits humains
que ce soit des arrestations arbitraires
d'activistes et de défenseurs des droits
humains en algérie des violences
policières au liban et et notamment
l'utilisation de gaz lacrymogènes de
canons à eau et cetera voir un usage
excessif et particulièrement
disproportionné de la force contre les
manifestants en irak où malheureusement
on dénombre plus de 500 morts parmi les
manifestants
le début de la contestation au mois
d'octobre dernier
donc là on veut réprimer ces
manifestations d'un autre poids aussi
qui est très important il ya une
participation massive et sans précédent
des femmes notamment au liban où la
femme libanaise s'était posée même comme
une héroïne inattendue la contestation
oui en fait les femmes dans la région
ont toujours participé de façon très
importante au mouvement de contestation
mais il est vrai que cette fois ci on en
parle davantage et qu'elles sont
vraiment non seulement dans les rangs
des manifestants
mais elles sont également dans
l'organisation et dans toute la
communication quelque part qui qui se
fait autour des revendications des
populations est effectivement donc ce
sont des contestations sans précédent
non seulement de par leur ampleur et
leur durabilité mais aussi de par leur
composition sociologique donc avec une
participation massive des femmes et mais
il ne faut pas oublier également que ce
sont des mouvements qui vraiment
transcende les clivages politiques
traditionnels les clivages religieux
communautaire et générationnelle
également quand un petit mot aussi sera
les médias sociaux aux six avaient joué
un rôle très important pendant le
printemps arabe le premier printemps
arabe
quel rôle on peut voir actuellement non
pour les médias sociaux est-ce que ça
stimule
oui c'est toujours c'est toujours
fondamentale mais il n'ya pas que ça
vous savez internet a été coupé à
plusieurs reprises en notamment donc il
faut on se fourvoie si on pense que en
coupant l'accès à internet on coupe que
la contestation se terminèrent le pied
de ces contestations exactement
exactement a toujours très éclairant
merci beaucoup yasmine et la veille
je vous en prie